En 40 años, Benito tendrá 11 veces la edad
que tiene actualmente.
¿Qué edad tiene Benito ahorita?
Y bueno, este es un problema de edad, así
que vamos a resolverlo con calma.
Lo primero que hay que hacer es ver lo que
queremos, y lo que queremos es la edad que
tiene Benito justo ahora...
justo ahora...
Y entonces, lo que nos conviene es definir una variable como la edad que tiene justo ahora.
Entonces, sea "x" igual a la edad que tiene
Benito actualmente, en este preciso momento.
"x" la edad...
edad que tiene Benito justo ahora...
La edad que tiene Benito actualmente y,
¿qué va a pasar en 40 años?
Bueno, nosotros nos queremos fijar y todo
está establecido en 40 años,
así que déjame ponerlo aquí.
¿En 40 años qué va a pasar?
Bueno, pues Benito va a tener 40 años más
de la edad que tiene ahorita,
es decir "x" más 40, va a tener la edad que tiene ahorita
que son "x" años, más 40 años,
es decir, Benito va a tener "x" más 40 años, muy bien.
Pero no solamente nos dice eso el problema,
lo que nos dice es otro dato muy importante.
En 40 años, Benito va a tener 11 veces su
edad, la edad que tiene justo ahora,
la edad que tiene actualmente.
Es decir, en 40 años, Benito va a tener 11
veces su edad, "x" más 40 tiene que ser igual
a 11 veces la edad que tiene ahorita, es decir 11 por "x".
Y entonces aquí ya nos surge la idea de tener
una ecuación, "x" más 40, lo que va a pasar
en 40 años va a ser igual a 11 veces su edad,
la edad que tenga en 40 años,
va a ser 11 veces su edad actual.
Es decir, 11 por "x", 11 veces su edad actual,
esto tiene que ser igual
a la edad que va a tener Benito
en 40 años, es decir, "x" más 40.
Y entonces, ¿cuánto es esto?
o ¿cómo resolvemos esta ecuación?
Bueno, lo primero que quiero que te des cuenta
es que ya la hicimos, porque tenemos una ecuación
con una sola incógnita, y de hecho lo que
vamos a hacer es resolver esta ecuación que
no se ve tan difícil de hacer.
Lo primero que voy a hacer es restar "x" de
ambos lados de la ecuación,
para que me quede todo el lado izquierdo, que dependa solamente de la variable "x",
entonces menos "x" por aquí, menos "x" por acá y
¿qué me va a quedar?
"11x" menos "x", bueno esto es, 10 veces "x"...
entonces déjame ponerlo...
10 veces "x"...
mientras que del otro lado, del lado derecho,
¿qué me queda?
"x" menos "x" se van, se eliminan, se cancelan,
son 0 y solamente me queda el 40.
"10x" es igual a 40, perfecto.
Pero yo lo que quiero no es el valor de "10x" sino de "x"
y por lo tanto, voy a dividir entre 10 ambos lados de la ecuación, 10 y 10 se van,
de tal manera que solamente me queda 1, déjame escribirlo aquí abajo, entonces "x" es igual a 40 entre 10,
40 entre 10 es 4, entonces...
¡Perfecto!
ya tengo que "x" vale 4 y "x" es justo lo
que yo quería, la edad que tiene Benito actualmente.
Ya puedo contestar que Benito
tiene actualmente 4 años...
4 años solamente tiene Benito...
¿Y en 40 años?
Pues en 40 años, Benito va a tener "x" más
40, es decir, 44 años
y sería muy bueno corroborar que realmente cumpla lo que dice nuestro problema,
es decir, que 44 sea 11 veces 4,
pero eso es cierto, 4 por 11 es 44.
Por lo tanto, hemos llegado al resultado.